[Musik]
Dieser Podcast wird Ihnen von der LMU
München präsentiert. Vielen Dank für die
Einladung, heute Nachmittag zu Ihnen zu sprechen. Es ist mir
eine große Freude,
hier zu sein.
Ich entschuldige mich, dass ich auf Englisch sprechen muss.
Ich habe kein Deutsch.  Ich fürchte,
aber ich weiß, dass Sie alle zweisprachig sind
und mit meinem Englisch zurechtkommen. Der spätere
Wittgenstein, von dem ich behauptete, er sei kein
transzendentaler Idealist, also haben Sie sofort
die Antwort auf die Frage,
aber ich werde noch ein
bisschen mehr sagen  Nun, das ist eine kühne
kryptische Behauptung, die unter anderem
nach einer Definition des
transzendentalen Idealismus schreit, und ich werde
zu gegebener Zeit eine Definition liefern, aber sie
bedarf auch einer sofortigen
Einschränkung, wenn sie behauptet, dass der spätere
Wittgenstein kein transzendentaler
Idealist war  Ich behaupte nicht, dass er
den transzendentalen Idealismus konfrontiert und
dagegen argumentiert hat,
noch weniger, dass er stattdessen einen anderen Ismus angenommen hat
, der Vik in Steins Co. völlig entgegengesetzt gewesen wäre
Konzept der Philosophie über das Konzept von
Vacant Stein Philosophie ist
eine Art Therapie und ihr Zweck ist es
, uns zu heilen, wann immer wir durch den Missbrauch
unserer eigenen Sprache von
unbeantwortbaren Fragen oder
Pseudofragen beunruhigt werden, die sich als tiefe Probleme darstellen, also ist es nicht der
Sinn der Philosophie hinzuzufügen
ismen Ich meine, wenn Sie im Laufe des
Philosophierens überhaupt irgendetwas bejahen,
dann nur, um zu zeigen, wie
bestimmte Wörter verwendet werden, und was man
bejaht, ist höchstwahrscheinlich keine
Plattitüde oder ein Gegenstand allgemeiner empirischer
Erkenntnisse, nicht etwas  muss
diskutiert werden, also je nachdem, wie genau
transzendentaler Idealismus definiert ist,
geht es die Philosophie entweder überhaupt nichts an
oder ist wahrscheinlicher ein bisschen Unsinn
,
der mit einem geeigneten philosophischen
Abführmittel
sehr gut aus dem System gespült werden muss, dann wie  Ich definiere
transzendentalen Idealismus gut, natürlich ist
der Begriff Kant, und ich möchte ihn
im weitesten Sinne kantianisch verwenden, aber im weitesten Sinne ist
Kantianisch das Operative  Kant
selbst hatte natürlich eine Lehre
speziell über die Natur von Raum
und Zeit im Sinn, wenn Sie den
transzendentalen Idealismus so definieren würden, wie Kant ihn
verstand, müssten Sie sich
auf Raum und Zeit beziehen, es gibt
jedoch heutzutage einen Trend in der Philosophie,
den ich anstrebe  Im Folgenden wird der Begriff in
einem erweiterten Sinne verwendet, der auf
natürliche Weise aus Dosen entstehen soll. Das
werde ich also tun. Ich werde mir
diesen Begriff aneignen und ihn auf eine Weise verwenden, die
ungefähr kantisch ist, aber es wird sicherlich
nicht Kant sein  Eigengebrauch nun hat Kant
selbst den Begriff verwendet, um für eine
von zwei Arten des Idealismus zu stehen, die andere
ist der empirische Idealismus. Er hat diesen
Kontrast Kants zwischen transzendentalem
Idealismus und empirischem Idealismus erhalten, und ich
werde Kant auch in dieser Hinsicht folgen,
aber wie im Fall des
transzendentalen Idealismus  Ich werde den
Begriff empirischer Idealismus und
im Übrigen Idealismus an sich ohne jede Einschränkung in einer Weise verwenden, die im Großen und Ganzen
eher kantisch als kans ver ist
Ich habe diese in das
Handout aufgenommen und hoffe, dass die Leute Zugang zu einer
Kopie des Handouts haben
Idealismus, wie ich es verstehe, ist die Ansicht,
dass die Grenze dessen, was unsere
Darstellungen beantworten, festgelegt ist  Teils
durch irgendein Merkmal der Vorstellungen
selbst werden die Grenzen dessen, worauf
unsere Vorstellungen antworten, gesetzt,
teilweise durch irgendein Merkmal der
Vorstellungen selbst. Mit einer
Vorstellung hier meine ich alles, was
der Realität entspricht und dadurch wahr
oder falsch ist, also schließen unsere Vorstellungen ein
unsere Gedanken beurteilen unsere Theorien als
solche und mit den Grenzen von etwas
meine ich seine wesentlichen Merkmale, so dass
Idealismus bei dieser Vorstellung die Ansicht ist,
dass die wesentlichen Merkmale dessen,
worauf unsere Gedanken und Urteile und
Theorien antworten, teilweise durch einige
Merkmale festgelegt sind  die gedanken urteile und
theorien selbst empirischer idealismus
schließt den reiter ein, dass die setzung
dieser grenzen in ihnen liegt  ist
selbst ein Aspekt dessen, worauf unsere
Darstellungen antworten. Der transzendentale
Idealismus schließt den Reiter ein, dass die
Festlegung dieser Grenzen jenseits davon liegt.
Es ist selbst kein Merkmal dessen,
worauf unsere Darstellungen antworten, und die
Grenzen sind relativ zu ihren Begrenzungen
, das heißt, sie schließen aus  gewisse
Möglichkeiten, wenn auch Möglichkeiten,
die darüber hinaus liegen
und was wir denken oder
beurteilen oder worüber wir theoretisieren können, also
werde ich diese
drei Begriffe
Idealismus empirischen Idealismus und
transzendentalen Idealismus verwenden. Ich sollte vielleicht
hinzufügen, dass ich es bin  Ich mache mir keine großen Gedanken darüber,
ob diese Verwendung mit der von jemand
anderem übereinstimmt, obwohl meine unmittelbarere Inspiration ebenso wie die
Konservendose
Bernhard Williams ist, der
diese Begriffe selbst auf die
Diskussion über Vik Kingston anwendet, wenn auch in seinem
Fall im Verlauf einer Diskussion, in
der er  kommt zu dem
gegenteiligen Ergebnis und vielen von
Ihnen ist Bernard
W  illiams arbeit auf diesem gebiet einige von
ihnen wissen es vielleicht nicht, aber
williams betont, dass der spätere vic in stein in gewisser weise ein transzendentaler
idealist war, und ich habe bereits gesagt, dass meiner
meinung nach vikram stein kein
transzendentaler war  Idealist, aber wie ich hoffe,
wird sich herausstellen, dass es weniger
Unterschiede zwischen Williams und mir gibt, als
es den Anschein haben mag, und sicherlich war
Williams einer der Hauptbezugspunkte für das,
was
jetzt folgt
Idealismus geht die Philosophie entweder nichts an
oder es ist ein Blödsinn
, der aus dem System gespült werden muss,
und ich will nicht widersprechen, dass der
spätere Wittgenstein, um es noch einmal zu wiederholen, meiner Ansicht nach kein transzendentaler Idealist war, aber
die Hauptsache  Dieser
Vortrag soll zeigen, dass Vicki Steins
Relevanz für den transzendentalen Idealismus, oder
vielleicht sollten wir sagen, seine Relevanz für
ihn, nicht darin liegt, dass er uns die Lizenz gibt
, ihn zu ignorieren, noch  Indem er die
Methoden liefert, um es endgültig zu entsorgen, aber
im Gegenteil, indem er uns trotz seines
Willens einen Anreiz gibt,
es anzunehmen, wird die Idee sein,
dass es Kräfte in Vic in Stein gibt
, die in die Richtung führen
transzendentaler Idealismus, und dies ist
einer der Gründe für das, was ich vor einiger
Zeit gesagt habe, dass es weniger
Unterschiede zwischen Bernard Williams und
mir gibt, als es den Anschein haben mag, dass
transzendentaler Idealismus vorliegt, obwohl
seine direkte Billigung
so völlig unpassend für Kingstonian wäre
ein wichtiger platz in vicki steins
werk oder vielleicht besser ausgedrückt:
es hat einen wichtigen platz in
vikins tinian exegese,
denn Vic ensteins philosophie beinhaltet
selbstbewusste aufmerksamkeit für den gebrauch von
sprache, das heißt, eine klare
ansicht zu haben, wie worte sind  verwendet, um darüber nachzudenken,
was Sinn macht und was nicht, sich
in seiner
Sichtweise oder seinen verschiedenen Sichtweisen zurechtzufinden, und das
sollte ich hier und sagen  An anderer Stelle in
dieser Vorlesung werde ich den Begriff
Perspektive verwenden, um eine Sichtweise auf die
Welt zu bezeichnen. Eine bestimmte Perspektive zu haben bedeutet
, einige Dinge als relevant für andere
zu behandeln, bereit zu sein, verschiedene
Verbindungen zwischen Dingen herzustellen,
auf bestimmte Ähnlichkeiten und Unterschiede
zu stoßen  Finden Sie einige Dinge natürlich, konzentrieren Sie sich auf
Aufmerksamkeit und dergleichen.
Selbstbewusste Aufmerksamkeit für den Gebrauch
von Sprache bedeutet oder beinhaltet auch das
Erkennen bestimmter Aussagen als
notwendig. Ein sehr einfaches Beispiel ist
die Aussage, dass sie nicht unsere Frau ist.
Solche Aussagen verkörpern keine
wesentlichen Behauptungen darüber  Die Welt, in der
sie die Wechselbeziehungen von Konzepten
für Vic in Stine registrieren, sagt, dass Ameisen, unsere
Frau, eine Regel ausspricht, anstatt
eine Behauptung aufzustellen, und zu sagen, dass Ameisen
weiblich sein müssen, spielt auf die Tatsache an, dass wir
jemanden nicht als Ameise zählen, es sei denn,
wir zählen auch die
Person  als weiblich, aber beachten Sie, wie die
Notwendigkeit dadurch begründet ist, dass der
Stylist der Kontingenzfiktion
die Ansicht zerstreute, dass ich  Wenn wir die
Bedeutung auf die beschriebene Weise
erforschen, erforschen wir eine unveränderliche, superphysische
Landschaft, als ob das Konzept einer
Bewaffnetheit und das Konzept der Weiblichkeit
Dinge wären, über die wir gerade gestolpert
sind, ein untrennbarer Teil des anderen,
nein, das ist kein leerer Stein
Wir konzentrieren uns auf unsere eigenen kontingenten Praktiken,
und darüber hinaus ist ein Teil von Vic in
Steins Genie seine besondere Gabe,
die Aufmerksamkeit darauf zu lenken, wie tief diese
Kontingenzen liegen
Die Art und Weise
, wie wir das tun, liegt natürlich daran, dass
wir vielleicht das Wort bewaffneter AUM-
Tee verwendet haben, um Onkels zu bezeichnen, aber wenn wir
selbstbewusst über unsere tatsächlichen Klassifizierungen nachdenken,
neigen wir dazu,
diese als bestimmten Einschränkungen unterworfen zu sehen
[Musik]
, stellen Sie sich das also vor  Menschen, die unter bestimmten
Umständen ein Wort verwenden, um grüne Dinge zu bezeichnen,
und die unter anderen
Umständen dasselbe Wort verwenden, um blaue Dinge zu bezeichnen
Dinge, von denen wir sagen möchten, dass sie
nicht ein einziges Konzept im Kopf haben können,
zählen nicht dazu, dass sie auf die gleiche
Weise weitermachen, aber Vic in Stine, der einige
seiner eigenen philosophischen Methoden auf diese
unsere Inkarnation anwendet, fordert uns auf
, noch einmal darüber nachzudenken  Um
so weiterzumachen, ist es nicht so,
dass er eine bestimmte bevorzugte Ansicht davon im Sinn hat
, für die er argumentieren möchte, sondern durch eine sorgfältige
Verflechtung von Hinweisen, Vorschlägen und
Beschreibungen verschiedener Fälle, in denen er
uns untersuchen lässt  vertieft die Sicht
, die wir bereits haben, und wir erkennen,
wie viel wir für selbstverständlich halten,
wenn wir jemanden zählen oder uns weigern,
jemanden zu zählen, als würde er auf die gleiche
Weise weitermachen, wenn verschiedene Tatsachen der Natur
anders gewesen wären, als sie sind und wie sie sind
Insbesondere wenn verschiedene Tatsachen der menschlichen
Natur anders gewesen wären, als sie sind,
dann hätten alle möglichen Verhaltensweisen
als auf die gleiche Weise fortgeführt gezählt werden
können, also stellen Sie sich zum Beispiel den
blaugrünen Fall sup vor  wie folgt ergänzt,
nehmen wir an, dass es periodische
atmosphärische Bedingungen gibt,
die grüne Dinge vorübergehend blau
und blaue Dinge grün färben, und die
Kontingenzen des Sprachgebrauchs beinhalten
all diese Tatsachen, und ganz
entscheidend, sie beinhalten unsere gemeinsamen
Empfindungen, unsere gemeinsamen Sinne dafür,
was natürlich und was hervorstechend ist  Unsere
gemeinsamen Ansichten, den Begriff zu verwenden, den ich
früher eingeführt habe, ohne diese
Kommunikation würden zusammenbrechen, wie
Stanley Cavell es wunderbar und berühmt
ausdrückt, und dies ist das Zitat auf dem
Handout das erste Zitat
auf dem Handout, dass wir im Großen und Ganzen
die gleichen Projektionen machen und verstehen  von Wörtern
in weitere Kontexte, ist eine Frage unserer
gemeinsamen Interessenswege und Gefühlsweisen,
Reaktionsweisen, unseres Sinns für Humor und
Bedeutung und eine Erfüllung dessen,
was empörend ist, was ähnlich ist, was
sonst, was eine Zurechtweisung, was Vergebung,
wann eine Äußerung eine ist  Behauptung, wenn
ein Appell, wenn eine Erklärung, der ganze
Strudel des Organismus verdickt Stei  n nennt
Lebensformen
, das ist ein wunderbares Zitat von
Stanley Cavell, das meiner Meinung nach
die Idee sehr gut wiedergibt. Vic und Stein
beschreiben Lebensformen. Cavell schließt
mit einer Anspielung auf diesen berühmten Satz. Vic
und Stein beschreiben Lebensformen als das
Gegebene, was sie sind  Es muss akzeptiert werden, dass ein
Teil dessen, was er meint, ist, dass es
in unserer biologischen Natur liegt, bestimmte Ansichten zu haben
, und dies kommt in der Tatsache zum Ausdruck,
dass wir letztendlich
auf bestimmte Weise auf unsere Umgebung reagieren,
die dazu beitragen, die Kommunikation zwischen uns aufrechtzuerhalten
, aber  Der Ausdruck Lebensform weist
noch mehr darauf hin, als dass wir auch
in verschiedene soziale Praktiken eingeprägt wurden
und infolgedessen bestimmte Dinge schätzen
wir bestimmte Dinge als selbstverständlich
ansehen wir uns bestimmten Autoritäten unterordnen wir
bestimmte Kanons der Rationalität akzeptieren und wir
bestimmte Verhaltensweisen annehmen  der Interpretation
all diese Dinge helfen dabei, unsere
natürliche Sichtweise in die voll
ausgeklügelte Sichtweise zu formen, in Übereinstimmung mit
der wir unsere Lingui produzieren
Heute ist Vicky Stein fest davon überzeugt, dass die
Erforschung der Sprache, die
die Philosophie charakterisiert, keine
wissenschaftliche Erforschung sein kann, und es gibt
viele Dinge, die er damit meint, zum
Beispiel meint er, dass die
Philosophie von jeglichem Anspruch auf Theorie und Systematik befreit werden muss,
er meint diese
Philosophie  eher beschreibend
als erklärend sein muss, aber etwas anderes, was
er meint, oder zumindest etwas anderes
, das sehr eng damit zusammenhängt und von
dem er sicherlich denkt, dass
Philosophie niemals völlig
losgelöst sein kann, hätten wir vielleicht gedacht, dass dies die
Art der Beschreibung unserer eigenen
sprachlichen Praktiken ist  in der
Philosophie erforderlich wäre etwas, dessen
Inhalt im Prinzip von jemandem erfasst werden könnte
, der die Sprache noch nicht verstand, und
wir
hätten vielleicht gedacht, dass es einen Einfluss auf
jemanden haben könnte, der die Sprache missverstanden hat,
aber für Vicky Stein ist eine solche Distanzierung
weder notwendig noch möglich Bernhard
Williams im Artikel zu w  Was ich
bereits erwähnt habe, bringt sehr gut die Art
von Dingen zum Ausdruck, die Vicky Stein stattdessen vorsieht,
und dies ist das zweite Zitat
auf dem Handzettel zu einer leeren stillen
Vorstellung. Wir können uns unsere Sprache
klarer machen, indem wir darüber sozusagen selbst nachdenken.
es bewusst
auszuüben, nicht indem wir Alternativen in Betracht ziehen,
sondern indem
wir uns a und reflexiv in unsere Sicht der
Dinge bewegen und spüren, wann man
durch das zunehmende unverständliche 'ti der Dinge am Rande ist,
betrachtet aus welchem Weg heraus man sich in
was hineinbewegt hat  Beim
Nachdenken wird einem bewusst,
wie wir weitermachen, und wie wir
weitermachen, hängt davon ab, wie wir denken und
sprechen und uns absichtlich und sozial
verhalten. Ein weiteres wunderbares
Zitat von Williams
diejenigen, die die Sprache falsch verstehen,
und natürlich müssen wir uns daran erinnern, dass
diese Leute sehr wahrscheinlich wir selbst
in einer anderen Gestalt sind, was Sie tun  in der
Philosophie ist es, Ihre eigenen
Missverständnisse zu korrigieren. Wie gehen wir mit
denen um, die die Sprache falsch verstehen?
Durch das, was wir sagen,
geben wir ihnen im Laufe dieser Reflexionen die
gleiche Art von Kontakt mit der Sprache, wie
wir es Kindern geben, denen wir nicht so viel erzählen
ihnen, wie die Sprache ist,
ihnen zeigen, wie sie ist, indem
wir sie der Sprache aussetzen, wir fordern sie auf, ermutigen
sie, sie einzuladen, ein angemessenes
Verständnis der Sprache zu erreichen, nicht von
außen, das heißt, nicht indem
sie sie in Bezug auf eine andere
Sprache interpretieren  die sie bereits verstehen,
aber innerhalb der Art von Dingen, die
Williams in diesem Zitat festhält, geht es
jedoch nicht nur darum, dass wir
die Sprache verwenden, während sie zuschauen,
wir beschreiben auch die Sprache,
wir machen konzeptionelle Verbindungen deutlich,
wir unterscheiden zwischen verschiedenen Formen
der Sprache  Wir enthüllen Unsinn
und dergleichen, aber das Bedeutsame
ist, dass wir all
dies in einer Weise tun, die ar ist  Letztendlich
unverständlich außer für diejenigen, die
verstehen, dass wir keine Wahl haben, können unsere
Beschreibungen nicht anerkannt werden,
außer aus der Sicht eines solchen
Verständnisses, so dass die Erforschung der
Sprache, die Vic und Stein ins
Auge fassen, daher ein reflexiver,
reflexiver, selbstbewusster Prozess ist, zu dem sie sich
bewegen  und her, in denen wir einen
bestimmten konzeptuellen Standpunkt aufrechterhalten, teilweise
indem wir Repräsentationen
produzieren, die nur von diesem Standpunkt aus produziert werden können
, mit dem ständigen Ziel,
den Standpunkt selbst im Fokus zu halten,
aber was ist das für ein Standpunkt, den ich bin?
jetzt unter Bezugnahme auf „gut“ habe ich
es als den Standpunkt charakterisiert, der implizit
in einem Verständnis unserer Sprache enthalten
ist, aber was ist das „gut“, diese Frage wiederum
lädt andere dazu ein,
wie genau Sprache
hier verstanden wird und wer darin  diese
diskussion auf unsere art und diese beiden
fragen kommen wie folgt zusammen was
in dieser diskussion ist unsere sprache nicht
englisch nicht deutsch nicht  Französisch ist
keine empirisch identifizierte Sprache
dieser Art. Das Beispiel,
dass Ameisen weiblich sind, das ich zuvor verwendet habe, hätte vielleicht
wie ein Beispiel für Englisch ausgesehen,
nur weil das die
Sprache ist, in der ich es präsentiert habe,
aber wenn es so wäre, wenn wir uns
speziell damit befassen würden  Englisch, dann
gäbe es keinen Grund zu der Annahme, dass die
relevanten Sprachpraktiken nicht
beschrieben werden können, außer für diejenigen,
die die Sprache bereits verstehen. Es
gibt kein Hindernis, die
Verwendung der Wörter are't und female in
beispielsweise Französisch zu beschreiben. Nein, das Beispiel hat
nichts Spezifisches  Im Zusammenhang mit dem Englischen sind
die relevanten Sprachpraktiken
wie unsere Weigerung, jemanden
als Ameise zu
zählen, es sei denn, wir zählen dies
als Frau, und wir schließen hier
einsprachige Sprecher des Französischen ein, die
selbst an dieser Praxis teilnehmen,
indem sie die Ausdrücke
tant und das Geschlecht Femina verwenden  Unsere Sprache
ist also eher eine Reihe von
konzeptuellen Ressourcen, und sicherlich ist dies
m  macht deutlicher, warum irgendjemand denken sollte,
dass es unmöglich ist, unsere Sprache zu beschreiben
, ohne sie zu verwenden, und es
absorbiert auch die Fiktion Stein einer Art
empirischen Idealismus, einer ziemlich verrückten und
interessanten Art empirischen Idealismus
, weil das, wie ich bereits bemerkt habe
, kontingent ist  Das englische Wort
aunt wird in der Weise verwendet, dass es so war, als hätte
vakant Stein die
Notwendigkeit in solchen Eventualitäten begründen sollen, da
dies gemeint hatte, dass die Notwendigkeit, dass
Ameisen weiblich sind, darauf zurückzuführen ist, dass Englischsprachige
die Wörter bewaffnet und weiblich auf eine
bestimmte Weise verwenden  dann hätte er
tatsächlich gesagt, dass die Grenzen der
Realität teilweise durch bestimmte historische
Zufälle gesetzt werden, die die tatsächliche Mechanik
der sprachlichen Repräsentation
betreffen, und eine Sache, die diese Art von Idealismus widerlegt,
ist, dass es immer noch
notwendig gewesen wäre, dass Ameisen weiblich waren und
a fortiori Ameisen wären immer noch
weiblich gewesen, selbst wenn die Wörter nicht und
Onkel ihre Bedeutungen
vertauscht hätten, wahr wäre es  dann
war der Satz nicht richtig, Ameisen sind
weiblich, aber das ist eine andere Sache
, tatsächlich wären Arme weiblich gewesen,
was auch immer wir herausgefunden haben, das ist Teil dessen,
was gemeint ist, wenn man sagt, dass
Ameisen weiblich sein müssen, es gibt jedoch Kräfte in
vakantem Styne  die es sehr
schwierig machen, dies im Griff zu behalten. Vicki
Stein begründet die Notwendigkeit nicht mit
einfachen Kontingenzen des Wortgebrauchs, aber wie
wir gesehen haben, begründet er sie mit
Kontingenzen. Unsere Sprache
könnte anders
gewesen sein  die
möglichkeit männlicher waffen und wenn ja, folgt daraus nicht
, dass es männliche
waffen gegeben haben könnte, oder wiederum folgt nicht aus der
tatsache, dass unsere arithmetik oder sprache
anders gewesen sein könnte, dass dies auch zweimal
nicht gewesen sein könnte, denn zugegebenermaßen wird
bekenstein darauf bestehen  dass auch zweimal
für notwendig ist, dass auch zweimal für
er sagen wird, ist eine Regel, und doch ist es eine
Regel nur aufgrund unserer
kontingenten Sprachpraktiken und nicht nur in dem
Sinne, dass wir  andere
Laute oder andere Inschriften verwendet haben könnte,
um dies auszudrücken,
gibt es nicht Vicks mögliche Gründe
dafür, zu sagen, dass, wenn diese Praktiken
zweimal unterschiedlich gewesen wären, zwei
keine Schlussfolgerung gewesen wären, die, wenn sie uns nicht
ein durch und durch
entnervendes Schwindelgefühl auslöst, gerecht zu sein scheint  Fällt eine
weitere Bestätigung eines ziemlich verrückten
empirischen Idealismus aus. Nun, Vick in Stein
muss so etwas eigentlich nicht sagen.
Ich denke, diese Größen sind für
ihn real, aber sie sind auf eine Weise real, die damit
vereinbar ist, dass er eine klare
Lösung für sie hat und ich  Ich werde in Kürze mehr darüber zu sagen haben,
was ich damit meine.
Vicki Stein kann wie folgt antworten: Es ist
nicht so, dass wenn unsere Praktiken
zweimal unterschiedlich gewesen wären, zwei nicht
vier geworden wären, sondern wenn unsere Praktiken
unterschiedlich gewesen wären, hätten wir so etwas nicht gehabt
Regel hätten wir so nicht gedacht,
aber es bleibt dabei, dass zweimal
zwei ist, denn notgedrungen darf nichts
als ordentliche Rechnung gelten, wenn
sie verletzt wird  Davon wiederum wäre unsere
Sprache möglicherweise anders gewesen, nicht
in dem Sinne, dass wir
die Möglichkeit männlicher Arme zugelassen hätten,
was wir
für unser Konzept einer Tante nicht hätten tun können, und unser
Konzept von Männlichkeit wäre nicht dieses Konzept gewesen
, wenn  sie hatten einander nicht ausgeschlossen
wissen, dass unsere Sprache anders gewesen sein könnte,
eher in dem Sinne, dass
wir diese Konzepte möglicherweise nicht hatten,
ähnlich ist die Kontingenz unserer
sprachlichen Praktiken die einfache
Kontingenz, dass sie überhaupt existieren, und
wie wir gesehen haben, ist es eine tiefe Kontingenz
viel Glück zum Beispiel, dass sich die Leute
nicht wegen des Wetters streiten
Grundlegende Berechnungen wurden korrekt ausgeführt, ein
Punkt, den Vic und Stein selbst
berühmt gemacht haben, aber insofern dies bedeutet,
dass es eine bedingte Grundlage für
das Notwendige gibt, gefährdet dies weder
die Notwendigkeit noch  bezeichnet die
Setzung jeglicher Grenzen der Realität durch irgendein
Merkmal unserer Repräsentationen und hinsichtlich
der Frage, wer wir da sind  Es gibt keinen
Grund zu der Annahme, dass diese
Frage keine endgültige Antwort zulassen sollte,
sobald verschiedene Angelegenheiten
geklärt sind, obwohl es tatsächlich auch keinen
dringenden Bedarf gibt, sie zu lösen, da
nichts, entschuldigen Sie mich, da nichts von dem,
was gerade gesagt wurde, von ihnen abhängt
Auflösung Die fraglichen Fragen
beinhalten, ob einer von uns zu sein bedeutet
, verschiedene Ansichten zu teilen oder nur in der
Lage zu sein, sie zu teilen, und ob letzteres in
welchem Sinn von möglich und so oder so, welche Ansichten,
ie auch im
er diese Angelegenheiten gelöst werden, wir sind in gew
sser Weise nicht nur englischspr
chige Personen  sie zu lösen wir sind eine bestimmte
gruppe von menschen auf andere wege sie zu
lösen wir sind alle menschen
auf andere wege sie zu lösen wir
schließen jedes
tatsächliche oder potentielle
wesen ein, mit dem menschen kommunizieren können, oder alle wesen, die menschen
als sprachproduzierend erkennen können
Darstellungen, so dass Fiktion Stein entlastet werden kann,
das Problem ist, dass es
extrem schwierig ist, hier aufzuhören, es ist
extrem schwierig  Wenn wir uns nicht vorstellen, dass sich der
Weg sozusagen ins Unendliche ausdehnt,
wenn wir die verschiedenen
Möglichkeiten oben betrachtet haben, fällt es uns schwer
, uns nicht als
alle möglichen Produzenten sprachlicher
Repräsentationen zu betrachten, und wenn wir in
diesen Begriffen denken, dann eines von zwei Dingen  passieren kann
, das erste, was passieren kann,
ist, dass die kontingenz
ganz verschwindet unsere sprache kommt dazu,
alternativlos zu werden jeder beweis, dass
etwas ein gebrauch der sprache ist, ist
automatisch ein beweis dafür, dass es sich um einen
gebrauch unserer sprache handelt die bezüge auf uns und
auf  Unsere Sprache ist dann tatsächlich
überflüssig und die Philosophie muss wieder
einmal als die Erforschung einer
unveränderlichen, superphysischen Landschaft angesehen werden, eine
Art Platonismus, jetzt, wo die
Möglichkeit eindeutig inakzeptabel wäre, Stein zu verdicken.
Das zweite, was passieren kann, ist, dass
die Kontingenz unsere bleibt  Die Sprache
lässt zwar Alternativen zu, aber angesichts der
Art ihrer Expansion erinnern Sie sich an das
Bild, dass wir uns ausdehnen  bis ins Unendliche angesichts
der Tatsache, dass diese
Alternativen nicht real sind, sind sie vorzeigbare
Alternativen. Wir und unsere Sprache sind
transzendent zu verstehen, nicht als ein
Aspekt dessen, worauf unsere
Repräsentationen antworten, sondern als eine Grenze dessen
, auf das unsere Repräsentationen antworten,
aber was  Das ist transzendentaler
Idealismus, und ich nehme an, es
wäre ebenso inakzeptabel, diese Möglichkeit einzuschränken
, weil sie inkohärent ist, sie
erkennt Alternativen zu unserer
Sprache an, die sie dennoch
nicht als Merkmale
von Alternativen zu unserer Sprache
anerkennt, sie sieht Kontingenz, wo sie sie anerkennt  dass
es nur notwendig ist, dass es als
Grenzen im Sinne von Begrenzungen wirft,
was es als Grenzen erkennt, was es
als Grenzen im Sinne von wesentlichen
Merkmalen erkennt,
so dass irgendwie, wenn Fiktion Steins Ansicht
gewahrt werden soll, der Drang, den Weg zu sehen,
sich auf diese Weise erweitern muss  widerstanden werden,
aber wieder gibt es Kräfte in Vic und
Stein selbst, die diesen Drang almo machen  Es ist
unwiderstehlich, sich der Art von
selbstbewusster Reflexion hinzugeben, die Vic in
Stein befürwortet. Wir können nicht umhin zu fragen, aber
was bedeutet letztendlich, dass jemand
bewaffnet ist, oder was wiederum bedeutet, dass
etwas grün ist
, können wir nicht anders, als diese Fragen zu stellen,
weil wir es können  Man muss sich unweigerlich über
die wesentliche Natur dessen wundern, auf das
unsere Darstellungen antworten, dessen
Charakter unserer Sprache ihren Sinn gibt
und dazu beiträgt, dass
wir wissen, dass Ameisen
weiblich sein müssen, und wir wissen, dass Frauen
ein bestimmtes biologisches Wesen haben müssen  Verfassung,
das sind unsere Regeln, aber was braucht
es letztendlich, damit die Dinge
so konfiguriert sind, dass
jemand bewaffnet ist oder so, dass
etwas grün ist, wenn ein großes Kontingent
für Sie da ist, was wir dagegen nicht aufbringen können
klar von der
Sprache getrennte Fragen jemand, der
wissen will, was es heißt, eine
Ameise zu sein oder was
gr  een besteht in kann nicht einfach
auf jemanden aufmerksam machen, der eine Ameise auf
etwas ist, das grün ist, und denken, dass
es darin besteht, weil es nicht
klar ist, worauf sie sich beziehen,
und jeder, der wissen will, woraus
etwas besteht, das grün ist, muss es tun
Beobachten Sie uns, wie wir miteinander
kommunizieren und verschiedene
diskriminierende Fähigkeiten ausüben, die wir
besitzen, nicht nur, dass eine solche Person
unsere Kommunikationshandlungen verstehen und
den Sinn unserer Klassifizierungen erkennen
muss, sie muss sehen, wie wir das
Konzept einer Bewaffneten oder das Konzept eines
Grünen anwenden  Sehen Sie, welche Rolle dieses
Konzept in unserem Leben spielt, sehen Sie, wie es uns hilft
, die Dinge zu verstehen, die eine solche Person
kommen muss, um unsere Lebensform zu teilen oder bereits zu teilen,
sie muss werden oder
bereits einer von uns sein, also können wir es nicht  Beantworten Sie
die Frage, außer indem Sie anerkennen,
dass das, woraus jemandes Sein nicht
besteht, oder woraus einige Dinge bestehen, die
grün sind, zumindest teilweise darin besteht,
wie wir weitermachen, und der einzige Weg, um zu
pr  Vielleicht ist dies ein ziemlich verrückter
empirischer Idealismus, den Weg
ins Unendliche ausdehnen zu lassen oder mit anderen Worten
anzunehmen, dass das Konzept, eine
Ameise zu sein, und das Konzept, grün zu sein,
nicht als Teil einer
superphysischen Landschaft angesehen werden können, um den Idealismus umkehren zu lassen
transzendental, wie wir bereits
festgestellt haben, und noch einmal, wie wir bereits festgestellt haben, ist ein
solcher transzendentaler Idealismus
inkohärent,
also wie kann Vit Constraint gut widerstehen? Ich
denke, er kann ihm widerstehen, indem er einfach
die Fragen verweigert, die
dazu geführt haben  eine bewaffnete bestehen oder woraus
einige dinge grün bestehen oder
zumindest dürfen wir diese fragen nicht
mit einer gewissen metaphysischen absicht stellen die
erste frage mag eine ganz gute
sein, wenn sie als bitte um
konzeptionelle klärung gestellt wird, und dann ist
sie es  damit beantwortet werden kann, dass eine Tante
die Schwester eines Elternteils ist, kann
die zweite Frage eine durchaus
gute sein,
wenn sie als Bitte um eine wissenschaftliche Erklärung gedacht ist,
und sie  ist dann
in Bezug auf Wellenlängen und den Rest zu beantworten,
aber die Fragen wurden nicht
auf diese harmlose Weise in
dem Gedankengang gestellt, den wir
zuvor betrachtet haben, und irgendwie müssen wir diese
Fragen sehen, wenn sie
falsch gestellt werden  als Pseudofragen
Symptome einer Krankheit, die selbst
noch auf Ians Therapie wartet, bleibt die Tatsache bestehen,
dass es eine Simulation von Vic in
Steins Werk war, die uns dazu veranlasste, die Fragen zu stellen.
Es war eine Simulation von Vic in
Steins Werk, die uns dazu verleitete,
das Transzendente zu bejahen  Idealismus und
das ist ein wichtiger Punkt, ohne den
diese ganze exegetische Annäherung an Vic
und Stein insgesamt schwerer zu
rechtfertigen wäre, gibt es Hinweise darauf, dass Vic in
Stein selbst die
vier Versuchungen der Frage verspürt, inwieweit
unsere Mathematik von
uns abhängig ist  Beispiel ist eines, mit dem er
selbst sehr unangenehm zu kämpfen hat,
also betrachten Sie dieses Zitat und das ist
auf Seite zwei des Handzettels das Zitat
fr  om philosophischen Untersuchungen, aber
mathematische Wahrheit ist unabhängig davon,
ob Menschen es glauben oder nicht
, das ist sicherlich der Gesprächspartner
überhaupt Sinn macht, kann vielleicht bedeuten, dass
die Menschen zu dem mathematischen Satz gelangt sind, dass
die beiden
Sätze völlig unterschiedliche
Verwendungszwecke haben, aber was würde dies bedeuten,
obwohl jeder glaubte, dass zweimal
zwei fünf wäre, wäre es immer noch vier vier,
wie wäre es für alle zu
Ich glaube, ich könnte mir zum Beispiel gut vorstellen,
dass die Leute eine andere
Rechnung oder eine Technik haben, die wir
nicht Rechnen nennen sollten,
aber wäre es falsch, und dann betrachten Sie
dieses Zitat als das nächste Zitat auf dem
Handzettel von. Wir haben ein
Farbsystem, wie wir ein haben  zahlensystem liegen die
systeme in unserer natur oder in der
natur der dinge
wie sollen wir es nicht ausdrücken i  In der Natur
von Zahlen oder Kommas hat
dieses System also etwas Willkürliches,
ja und nein, es ist sowohl dem
Willkürlichen als auch dem Nichtwillkürlichen verwandt,
und dann das letzte Zitat auf dem
Handout Bernhard Williams Antwort auf
dieses Zitat von Finkelstein die
Zurückhaltung  darüber, wie man es ausdrückt, kommt
aus dem Pop-Problem, wie man eine
vermeintliche philosophische Wahrheit formuliert, die, wenn
sie ausgesprochen wird, als
empirische Falschheit oder schlimmer noch Vic in
Steins Bedeutungstheorie aufgefasst werden muss in
Richtung eines transzendentalen Idealismus, den
wir treiben  es in Formen zu
formulieren, die, wenn überhaupt
, falsch verstanden werden müssen, also denke ich, dass es hier ein
echtes Problem gibt. Meine eigene Ansicht ist,
dass eine angemessene Antwort auf dieses Problem
sich auf die frühere Arbeit von vakant Stein
und insbesondere auf mich stützen muss  Ich denke, es muss sich
auf die Unterscheidung zwischen Sagen
und Zeigen stützen, von der Vic Constrain
früher gedacht hatte, dass er ihm eine besondere Lizenz
gegeben hat, bestimmte Arten von Unsinn zu unterstützen,
einschließlich in  meiner Ansicht nach transzendentaler
Idealismus,
aber das ist, wie sie sagen, eine Verpflichtung
für eine andere Gelegenheit, danke